Roger stone ladies and gentlemen is here
on Jim Norton and Sam Roberts Roger
gentleman how are you excellent I kind
of feel I know how the Christians felt
when they were being led into the
Coliseum that's not good
well I mean this weekend's laughable it
is uh just a tsunami of fake news from
the left the Atlantic Daily Beast I read
those nothing to Huffington Post and
it's all nonsense as Julian Assange
himself said and I quote Roger stone is
a rather canny spinmaster but we've had
no communications with him whatsoever
okay Roger stone it's a frame job
can you describe though there were these
emails going back and forth where you
were complaining that bad you you said
hey I will I'll be happy to tell bad and
if he'd get back to me what what
information is those emails describing
yeah I think it needs some background
Julian Assange said in June of 2016 on
CNN that he had a treasure trove of
material on Ellery he sent it again on
Fox on August 24th I had a source as I
have Ted said Randi critical we can come
back to that who told me it was big that
it would destroy Hillary it was
devastating a bombshell and as you know
I hyped that very aggressively on
Twitter not to aggrandize myself but to
get as much voter and media attention to
the disclosures when they came as
possible that's called politics let me
ask you this Roger Assad renowned okay
asaji announced that he would do a press
event on October 2nd everybody assumed
this was the big moment it got huge pre
hype publicity on the second he held the
press conference but he released nothing
and Bannon reached out to me not the
other way around and said so what was
that about and I said to Bannon one that
he had delayed release out of security
concerns he was afraid they were going
to kill him remember hillary talked
openly about hitting him with a drone
secondly that he would release material
every week for the next ten weeks and
had said that all the u.s. election
related material would be released by
Election Day that was but reported by
Politico five hours earlier than ban and
asked me so nothing I said in an email
and was not published information so you
didn't have anything private before
before they well I was I was looking at
the emails and it did you didn't make it
seem like you were reporting on stuff
that was already reported on you you
said at one point he's scared when Steve
Bannon asked you why didn't he say
anything you swore you know what was
that you said he was scared and the
language that you were using in your
emails made it seem like either you did
have intimate knowledge of Julian
Assange that you would know from talking
to him or that you wanted Steve Bannon
and the Trump people to think that you
had so was there a part of you because
they also in the email chain it would
appear that Steve Bannon
did not take you very seriously and was
not responding to your emails did you
see the way this have you seen the way
this guy addresses I don't take in
Barrie's we call him sloppy Steve by me
the guy I mean the guy chases down hobos
I am Roger that's a fair question but
did you want because at the time at the
Bataclan but at the time Roger you did
do it at the time Steve Bannon was
deeply embedded with Trump yeah it did
seem like maybe you wanted to be a
little bit closer did you want the Steve
bannon's of the world to think that you
had an intimate connection with Julian
Assange it was immaterial to me I was
trying to win I was hoping and by the
way the email doesn't imply that
whatsoever let me also say the reason
Bannon has leaked this email is clear to
us the story in Reuters that the US
Senate Intelligence Committee is now hot
on his trail regarding his involvement
with Cambridge analytical and and the
boosting of several hundred million
Facebook Records illegally so this is
why I think he's trying to throw
my way the idea that I was a 40 year
relationship with Donald Trump himself
would need to suck up to Cory
Lewandowski or Dave bossy or two of the
other guys who have testified against me
Lewandowski is the guy I had called a
[ __ ] in the movie stone cold truth
I remember get me Roger stone think
that's his motive and boss sees motive
is that is that he had been in attempted
to take credit for delivering Bill
Clinton's female victims to this debate
to unnerve Hillary and I under his
females it showed that that was my idea
that was your idea Mansoor I wrote the
book about it though Clinton's war on
women I urged the Trump campaign
specifically Donald Trump and Paul
Manafort at the time to showcase those
women to demonstrate how Hillary had
abused women right yes that was my idea
so that's the motive in the emails
though it did not I think that there is
an implication in the emails that you at
least wanted people to believe that you
did have a connection to Julian Assange
because every time you talked about him
in any way it was whatever three emails
that I read in the emails that you put
out you did not write things like well
what I've heard is or what I've read is
you answered every question about Julian
Assange with the authority of knowledge
not I haven't talked to Julian Assange
yeah like with all due respect where did
I say Julian told me well you didn't say
that but but you you you not saying I
read you saying here is the answer
implies to the person reading it and you
know language very well it's like saying
this Roger if you're out with a pretty
girl huh if you're out with a pretty
girl and you didn't have sex with her
and someone goes did you [ __ ] her
instead of going no you go I don't kiss
and tell because you want people to
think a certain thing it's the same okay
I must say I I love you guys but I
reject your implication it doesn't say
anything of the kind I just answer
authoritative Lee if I said to you right
Roger if I said to you if I said to you
no no no no no Jim Norton loves [ __ ]
no no Jim not sue you for slander
you couldn't now I could turn around and
tell you yeah he tweeted that but when I
tell you that
and when I say it like that you my
audience is gonna go Oh Sam mustn't Sam
I know Jim yeah Jim must have he must
know that Jim likes them even more than
he says it kind of doesn't work that way
you try to put words in my mouth where
did I say I learned from aside WikiLeaks
told me or I said you said Julian
Assange was scared he was no I mean let
me address that if I mad if you go back
to the stone-cold truth my blog on March
9 two hundred twenty eighteen I write
that Randy credit code told me when
Assange did not deliver the material on
October 2nd as expected that that
assigned his lawyers had convinced him
that there was a threat to his life he
was concerned for his personal security
I wrote that at the time it's a marker
go back and look at it that is what I
refer to how does Randy credit go and I
still ready try to go with the company
so how does he know so much Randy credit
Co source is a woman lawyer who he has
been associated with professionally for
over 30 years they worked at the same
foundation so his defense that he could
not have been my source regarding the
WikiLeaks disclosure and the power of
them in late July because he did an
interview Assange until late August is
irrelevant that is his source if you've
seen Randy critical how do you think he
got the interview with the signs for
WBAI well let me acknowledge
she interceded to get in the interview
she is his source and let's remember the
information that he gives me is very
general the information is devastating
it's a bombshell it will take out
Hillary and I hyped that what I'm guilty
of here is is bluffing hyping posturing
to drop okay you're a media attention to
the disclosures that's called politics
it's not illegal
did you but let me ask you did you take
and pass lie-detector test yes I
actually took two polygraph tests at the
direction of my new lawyer
Bruce Rogue ow
who has represented Donald Trump on some
landmark decisions he's a very good
lawyer and he selected two analysts who
are the most prominent guys in the
country to look at the results in other
words I didn't just go to lie detectors
are uh yeah Industry heads lie detector
Emporium right you know and and we you
know they show that I told the truth
regarding never having contact with
WikiLeaks regarding having never
received anything from WikiLeaks
regarding critical being my source I
passed a polygraph now some will say
well that's not admissible in court
that's true but the FBI and the US
government uses them all the time but
should you be sorry Roger should you be
outing Randy as a sort like if someone's
a source of something is it is it bad to
out them as your source so what made you
know it is in fact which is why I was
reluctant to do so before the House
Intelligence Committee I explained his
role in detail but in my initial
testimony I declined to give his name at
the end of that session several members
Republicans said to me look son if you
want to get this over with him clear the
air we're gonna need that name and after
consulting with my lawyers I turned it
in that's when Randy went crazy on me
that's he was very very angry so this
idea that that he is not my source is
false the timing of his interview with
Assange is irrelevant his information is
coming from a WikiLeaks lawyer and the
idea that I'm threatening him it's true
I'm very angry at him not for lying I'm
angry at him for his failure to tell the
truth Roger I said why would why would
Randy tell you this when you guys are
polar ends of this opposite of the
spectrum politically and ideologically
why would Randy choose to give this to
you well first of all Randy is at that
point a Bernie Sanders supporter and he
is is violently opposed to Hillary
Clinton as I am secondarily Randy and I
have worked together on drug reform
matters against New York State
Rockefeller drug laws are the most
draconian racist
a drug laws in the country at that time
while they have been reformed some they
still need more reform as a matter of
fact so we have a you know I'm I'm a
libertarian conservative I'm Pro gay
marriage I'm tow marijuana and have been
for you know thirty years four years so
Randy and I have some common ground
there plus he's entertaining the guy
does the best Dick Nixon impression of
anybody better than David Frye better
than rich little the best Nixon I've
ever heard I spent a lot of time with
Nixon so this is going back to you
saying bluffing because I think when you
just said that if you're guilty of
anything it's this that this and
bluffing and I I think that that goes
back to our initial point where if
you're not if you never talk to Julian
Assange and I believe you when you tell
us that you wouldn't lie to us I don't
believe that you didn't want Steve
Bannon and the Trump people to not to
you didn't actively want them to believe
that you were talking to them and that
that's what you were bluffing like I
think that that is mine them both I
think that you wanted them here you
actively or wanted them to think that
because and I tell you I'm looking at
the emails right now you said to Steve
ban and when he finally emailed you back
quote he thinks they are going to kill
him and the London police are standing
done i pressing down whatever that
doesn't matter but but what i'm saying
is when you use that pronoun he that
sounds like and you know camillino
language that sounds like somebody who
has spoken to Julian Assange earlier
could you scroll up one Troy somebody
has to never you would never win that
one in court somebody asks you is never
win that one in court no but I don't I
don't think that you I'm not saying that
it means that we don't think you spoke
to him but I think it means that you
wanted Steve Bannon to think that you
spoke to him you said earlier when
somebody asked you if it was big you
said it is I tell Bannon but he doesn't
call me back two parts there you saying
it is is saying it again like Jim said
with authority saying I know that it is
not somebody's told me that it is and
you saying I tell Bannon but he doesn't
call me back
sounds to me like someone who's a little
salty
this DVB won't return their calls at
that point I was I was trying to explain
political strategy to Steve remember I'd
like to look Steve has never elected
anybody to anything in his life so what
I like to get his ear yes but this idea
that I have some need to suck up to him
or to his order his lieutenant
Lewandowski and and Dave bossy a man
whose IQ if it was one point lower you'd
have to water him and what do I care
what the Trump campaign thinks would be
not in the slightest what did you call
Lewandowski what did you call no and
dusky I said in Polish the word
Lewandowski translates to [ __ ] now
Michael Cohen is your relationship with
him still strong I know I know Michael
uh Michael's the Democratic you know and
now he's acting like the Democrat he is
come never wanted him anywhere near
politics you noticed he had no role in
the campaign no job in the White House
no federal appointment and I now think
it's very sad that you know his current
handlers are using him as a cudgel
to beat up Trump but as a lawyer on this
is what bothers me about him shouldn't
he not be saying this stuff as somebody
who was once client/attorney privilege
how was he allowed to go out and just
say all this private stuff yeah well
first of all they violated the
attorney-client privilege when they
prosecute they shouldn't be able to just
go into his emails and go into all of
his records but they were by claiming
that he was part of a conspiracy the
truth is the campaign finance charge to
which he has pled in other words that
that he paid off stormy for her silence
and was reimbursed by trumps is so weak
he would never have pled guilty if they
didn't already have him also have am on
tax evasion and bank fraud charges so
they they cooked up a political charge
that would be damaging to Trump they
thought although no one seems to care
whether he tagged stormy or not now
uh but do you think he did do you think
he did yeah I think it's probable yeah
in his day was one of the great playboys
of all you have no proximate is what
he's a cocksman he's a cocksman hey
Roger
what is he certainly was in his day
right what is Julian Assange think of
you getting in all this trouble if you
talk to him back what is Julian said
what is his idea I have no idea
a woman journalist who's interviewed him
tells him tells me that he finds me
amusing originally he found me
irritating there is a exchange that I
turned over to the House Intelligence
Committee in which is flax you know blow
me off when I complained about the fact
that they dumped on me but I've had no
direct contact with him I admire him in
all honesty he doesn't do anything the
Washington Post and The New York Times
don't do although he does it better
noting Assange has ever published over
11 years has been questioned in terms of
its authenticity or accuracy so you get
classified or information that's
embarrassing to governments including
the Trump administration and he
publishes it well and that is if that's
a crime and he's going to be prosecuted
for it then you've got to prosecute the
New York Times in the Washington Post in
the Wall Street that's truly do the same
thing do you think the Ecuadorian
Embassy is going to boot him it
certainly appears that way oh now it
appears that way now see now that now
now you could attribute that to me
because I just said it right but it from
what I read
I think his time grows short if he comes
here you know I do have a selfish
interest I'm certain that he would
testify
honestly that he and I and WikiLeaks
never had any communication and that I
never received anything from them
including allegedly hacked emails when
Julian was supposed to release all that
Hillary Clinton stuff and he didn't and
he got scared what did you say to him
that gave him the guts to finally
release a good question I didn't
what was the pep talk in fact the
textured the chain at that point is I at
credit code tells me that he has stood
down the lawyers have warned him that
his life's in danger I say what's going
to happen he says he's going to do the
right thing I think I think it will
publish and it does on October 7th he
does the first release now there's a
theory out there that somehow after the
famous Billy Bush grab them by the
you-know-what [ __ ] Cooter's release is
released I keep forgetting where we're
on serious yeah and the timing of
Assange is really not really that right
after that when I have nothing to do
with the coordination of anything my
information is all coming except your
wardrobe credit go critical and what I
read you know you don't so be a genius
to read the WikiLeaks Twitter feed and
to set a Google News Alert and read
every interview Julian Assange has done
you do if you got kicked off Twitter
yeah well I can use my wife's account
okay now could you get us a tour of the
White House probably not at this moment
can you get us a tour of the Ecuadorian
embassy when's the last time you were in
London comment I was in London to speak
to the Oxford Union the prestigious
Oxford Union earlier last year I also
spoke to the Cambridge Union which was
great because the students there while
they disagreed with me they were
respectful
we had a very vigorous dialogue but
there was no name-calling there was no
shouting my [ __ ] that kind of
thing are you enjoying this whole
process sometimes a word a descriptive
word just hit something or someone so
from aus yeah now are you enjoying this
whole thing the fact that you're you're
really a big part of this entire mess
you don't seem like you're too upset
well it's not a question of whether I am
upset or not but the average person even
those in politics who are accused of
wrongdoing go silent they they go to
their lawyers and they stop talking and
they turn everything over to the lawyers
I think when that happens people say oh
that guy's guilty you know you notice he
was accused you know by Chris Cuomo of X
Y & Z and he didn't respond so I think
it's important to get out there and
respond
I mean CNN has to show the other night
in which they reveal a text in which
credit code tells me he has a subpoena
from the special counsel and I respond
with an expletive here's what man
doesn't tell you he has no subpoena from
the special counsel he doesn't get one
until eight months later he's be asking
me late at night it's why I blow him off
with a you know with an expletive so I
mean it's an absurdity five times he
tells me he has subpoenas when he
doesn't have them if there's anybody
who's enjoyed the media attention that
this is brought them it would be you
know our favorite impressionist Randy
critic oh well Roger stone we always
appreciate you giving us the cold stone
truth you know and just be in there for
us yeah we enjoy you Roger
give us a scoop how about this then a
I'm you have a scoop give it to the kids
we'd lie well let me said let me say
this first of all anybody who's
listening who wants to help stone
Defense Fund calm does need money this
is very expensive this has hurt my
business
it has threatened the financial security
of my family I'm gonna fight for my life
and it's a smear job it's a frame and I
intend to fight and it's the opportunity
come on shows with guys like you give me
an opportunity to explain my side of it
you ask tough questions that's right but
I appreciate being here